ازمه سقف الدين الامريكيه بدات تتجلى اولى
ملامحها الخارجيه بقطع الرئيس جو بايدن
لزياره كانت مقرره لاسيا وجزر المحيط
الهادئ قبل ذلك حذرت وزيره الخزانه
الامريكيه جنات يدين هذا الشهر من نفادي
السيوله الامريكيه بحلول الاول من الشهر
المقبل ان فشل الكونغرس في رفعي او حتى
تعليق سقف الديون الوصول الى سقف الديون
يعني ان حكومه الولايات المتحده غير قادره
على اقتراض المزيد من الاموال وهو ما
سيقود الى تعثر كبير وتبحث الاداره
الامريكيه مع الكونجرس الطرق الممكنه
لمعالجه مشكله سقف الدين البالغه قيمته 31
تريليون و400 مليار دولار الرئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن التقى بقيادات الكونغرس بمجلسيه
النواب والشيوخ واعتبر بعد الاجتماع ان
عدم الاتفاق بين الجانبين سيكون مضرا
بالاقتصاد الامريكي وايضا المواطنين وقال
ان التخلف عن السداد ليس خيارا مطروحا
ابدا
[موسيقى]
لقد انهيت للتو
مع زعماء الكونجرس بشان مسار العمل للتاكد
من ان الولايات المتحده لا تتخلف عن سداد
ديونها لاول مره فوفقا لوكاله مودز
للتصنيف الائتماني فان اقتصادنا سيصبح في
حاله ركود وما يقرب من ثمانيه ملايين
امريكي سيفقدون وظائفهم في حال حصول ذلك
لقد اوضحت في اجتماع اليوم ان التخلف عن
السداد ليس خيارا ولا ينبغي ان تمنع
الخلافات السياسيه بين الاحزاب الكونجرس
من ايثاء الولايات المتحده بالتزاماتها
فلم يسبق لنا ان تخلفنا عن سداد ديوننا
ولن نفعل ذلك ابدا لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات